[Music]  here at home today adult football teams  got in the holiday spirit during the  annual big money football Turkey Bowl  teams from all across the country  competed in the football tournament at  Desert Pines high school teams were  vying for the grand prize of 15 thousand  dollars organizers say it's a great way  to bring the community together during  the holiday season  I took a lot of troubleshooting it took  a lot of trying to figure out exactly  how we can make it work and how it could  be beneficial for everybody but man here  we are just a great you know I'm saying  a good healthy safe fund for the  community to bring us all together to  enjoy each other's company  there was also a turkey giveaway during  that event a hundred turkeys rather were  donated from people all across the  community you can find more information  on the tournament on our website  8newsnow.com